okay cool
okay so uh welcome everybody another
edition of one on one and this time i've
got uh lana with me from learning candy
lana do you want to give a quick intro
for uh for anybody watching
sounds good thanks so much evan for this
opportunity um i've been learning so
much from you and from your videos i
can't believe i'm talking to you
so um i am a mompreneur what they call a
mompreneur and i recently started
my
first business which is learning candy
learning candy is
a company with a mission to help
families raise successful kids
so what that means is for
uh little kids it's all about uh getting
excited about learning
and for big kids it's about inspiring
them
uh to become action action-conscious
confident self-aware happy individuals
um
i
envision this as a brand that can go
multiple options
um my first line of products actually is
what i call learn where um
which are
um
apparel and proper different products
with educational and inspirational
designs for little kids
so um i started company late last year
and
i um
i started it as a b2c business
i've been trying to follow a lot of your
advice i've been trying to build
community i've been building you know
i'm trying to build a movement for
people who are excited you know who want
to get kids excited about learning who
want to raise successful kids
i'm going okay and you know pretty good
pretty good i'll see but i'm also
finding out that um
growing a business
one customer at a time it's a bit you
know slow
it's
quite expensive and it's not as
efficient as i had hoped
so what i'm hoping for is maybe
it gets some advice from you or some
feedback on how to
bring this product these products to
market
in a more
possibly b2b way um
how to scale faster possibly how to get
a distribution
how to grow a bit faster in a more
efficient way um
that's what i was hoping to get some
help yeah this is cool so uh
you sent me this really cool shirt that
my son loves to wear it says future
entrepreneur
uh
and he loves it and he just took his
school photos and he insisted on wearing
that shirt to his school so
that was nice
that was very exciting yeah so
how many how many products you have out
right now
how many sorry how many products say
again how many products
there are about let's say 15 different
designs um
and they're all what i have is love
no no um here's what i have is i have
about 15 to 20 different designs they
are designs for little kids those are uh
educational related subjects such as i
have the solar system on apparel on
t-shirts for example and other products
which i'll explain more i have um
things like farm animals for the
smallest kids i have um
marine animals and the like okay so for
the little kids let's see for toddlers
for beings and toddlers and then for
older kids um i have products such as
um
inspirational messaging confidence no
bullying future ex like entrepreneur or
future doctor kind of to inspire
professions
um so
the designs these designs are not only
on t-shirts but also in a variety of
products i started using you by using
your advice to kind of start it cheap um
not cheap but inexpensively sorry
uh inexpensively and i am using a
print-on-demand service
for my backhand
um that helped me by you know at least
getting the business started uh without
a huge investment so that print on
demand service is offering multiple
products with the same designs i can put
these the same products on bags
on
um
placemats
on
very sky apparel
and a variety of products i would say
about 15 to 20 products at least
so this is kind of the breakdown
i realized
i stopped using this print under me and
then start using my own inventory i'll
have to go down in the number of
products i'm offering
right no that's okay
what's the most successful product so
far what's the message
the message is
math is for girls
math is for growth
math is for girls this is to inspire
girls
to go into mathematics
uh i have other ideas for going into
math history or sciences for girls but
this is very
this is very so far people seem like it
yeah
cool and what age group was that is that
the young kids or the older kids
i've seen people
from both younger and older age group
getting those
interesting
you have a really important
mission
that you're on right
like trying to build up the confidence
in kids and get them excited by learning
is something that any
parent
gets and understands
and if i may
sorry
sorry i want to chat something else
yeah go ahead
all right um
this is not just about products uh this
is about
um really it's like a movement and we
are also also offering educational and
inspirational resources for parents to
help them raise these successful kids
so
we have various articles and
i'm hoping to expand on that this is all
free resources these are free resources
that we have on our website
so it's not only about selling products
it's about also helping people
raise successful kids bringing up you
know awareness
to these issues such as confidence such
as chase
how to
raise kids with these issues
learningcandy.com yes right okay
cool
and your tagline here is raising
successful training
okay
so
i'm trying to think how do you make this
more important for people because you
have a really important message it's
just not being spread
exactly so i was hoping again again you
know of course i'm learning from you
evan um i'm i was thinking in directions
of how can i make partnerships right uh
with whom could i make partnerships
to help me grow this
so i would back up a step okay so i went
to your website and it's
i'm on here and i'm seeing the t-shirts
and there's a lot of text and uh
you know it's kind of difficult to read
i like the picture of the girl there
with whatever t-shirt she has on
what i would think about is try to model
a company like nike
so if you look at nike
they don't focus just on the products
that's right you're being very product
focused here where you have an important
mission nike
nike wants to promote
athletes right they care about athletes
and performance and that comes across if
you go to their if you see their
advertisements if you see their
brochures you see their website it's not
just product in your face it's making me
feel something
and then from there i'm gonna go out and
buy a nike shoe i'm gonna buy because
of the message that they stand for
not
not because of the actual product itself
right you don't see nike comparing how
their product is against reebok or puma
or any other companies
and you have such an important message
that i would think the best way to get
people that you have something that's
really shareable
not just the actual product itself but
the message right that's right
i would start thinking about how can you
build this community in this movement
not just around the products but how
every day you're sharing
something about how to make your kids
smarter and how to make your kids care
more
right and
not just um
not just a practical
how-to but something that makes you feel
something
some inspirational right definitely
inspirational and relates to kids right
like that that girls love math
is cool right like it makes people
it makes people think and it gets them
like that's something that could be
shared
but if you also had if you think about
things that you can put into a picture
or tweet something that is inspirational
that relates to your message that even
have if it has nothing to do with
your products your t-shirts or your bags
or whatever
it's something that gets people to care
right like people right now don't care
enough
about your company even the customers
that you have
right you want them
spreading your message like crazy
right you want them buying
another thing and another thing and
another thing and so
the website when i get there
should make me feel
something
okay right and your twitter i don't know
if you're on twitter your facebook you
should be because this is a
a highly social
kind of campaign right
so what do you do on twitter
well so far i've been sharing some of
the helpful articles on various issues
relating to raising children
relating to you know how to raise
successful children and i don't define
successful by being wealthy of course no
it's about being confident it's about
about you know developing the whole
child it's about early education we try
to i also try to spread the message
about the importance of early learning
for the kids zero to three so i've been
sharing a lot of those kind of
articles and resources
and i do get some good feedback from
people people are saying oh this is
really important stuff
um but um
you know it's going slowly okay i have
to admit it's going it's moving along
but definitely
you know slowly so i this is what i've
been doing and you know going v2 people
you know directly to consumers so i'm
trying
i should try to
you know try to sell
wholesale or try to continue building
this momentum
yeah and the thing with b2c to make it
work partnerships can definitely work um
but you need to get
people talking about you right that's
how you scale because you can't be going
one to one to one each time
and i look at your twitter feed no
the two things i would suggest for you
is one
making your message a little easier
for people to
understand and share okay so
you know your
your homepage has raising successful
kids your twitter feed says
every child deserves a kind of curiosity
confidence and action conscious
inspiration they need to succeed
it's just too long
you know like it says what you do but
it uh it doesn't make me feel anything
right so okay try to get it down to like
what's the one word so i you know i have
belief here right that's easy to share
everybody gets it all of the stuff i
post is about believe it's easy for
people to share
what is learning candy in one word
you know maybe you already know it or
maybe you have to do some thinking about
it but figure out the one word so it's
easy
to share your stuff right so if i see a
parent i can say oh you have to talk you
have to go check out learning candy it
is
x because i'm never going to remember
learning candy
is all about the curiosity confidence
and action conscious inspiration kids
need to succeed right it's like
it's a huge mouthful people won't share
that so it is what you do but you have
to make it easier so i would try to get
it down to one word that you can put
into a hashtag so that people can share
it
uh the other thing is
the content that you're posting
uh is great
it is definitely value-add very
practical
um you know you're not just posting
fluff it's here here are things to
remember to raise a successful child
that's great
on top of that
the challenge with it is
it's too
in here
it's too uh
it's too practical so the practical
stuff is great
what's missing is the emotional part
right there are some things that if you
see a quote or if you see a picture
it makes you feel something
right if you see a girl wearing that you
know math uh
girls girls love math or math is for
girl whatever it is you know that might
make you feel something i'm sure you've
come across
quotes or pictures or other things
online that you look at and in a second
you love it
you know for me it might be quotes from
famous entrepreneurs there's some that i
love i look at like it just makes me
feel excited and that can happen in a
second
and so i try to share those things with
my community so the same thing related
to parenting or successful children if
it's quotes
um or pictures or something that just
hits people on an emotional level and
you're lucky you're in a business that
people are highly emotional
about their kids
right you're not selling toilet paper
here you're selling
things that people actually care about
and so you want to use that
advantage and you could be the own asset
test right so the things that get posted
on my facebook page
i like them like they make me
excited as an entrepreneur and hopefully
people who are reading that get excited
too
so things that get you excited as a
parent
you want to be sharing that stuff you
know on top of the content maybe maybe
you build out you're posting
you're posting while you're posting
maybe once a week
every two weeks i guess you're kind of
on and off um
i'd be posting a lot more of those
emotional quick sharing things and be
known as the the person who
inspires children or whatever your word
is
and it generates curiosity that makes
people wanting to come right if they
keep saying learning candy as
the the
maybe not creating this stuff but you're
you're curating it you're sharing it
right the stuff that i'm sharing
it might be a quote from steve jobs or
whoever it is you know i'm not making
that stuff up i'm just sharing it but i
become known as a person who
shares entrepreneurship stuff
i don't talk too much about products
that i sell
and all that but it it's there and
people want to learn more about it they
find out about it and
and they buy
but it's not in your face
hey you know buy my new guy this thing
is for you and you go to my website you
don't just see products everywhere you
want people to feel something
before they'll end up making a purchase
from you
yeah so it starts with your one word
like what is the one word that defines
learning candy something easy shareable
when you see it you get excited by it
and then make that flow through your
website your social media stream you
know so it's easy for people to share
your stuff
uh that's that's a better b2c approach
so it's not i'm not just buying the
future entrepreneur shirt i'm part of
this movement right you have to name the
movement make it easy to understand you
look at popular movements you look at
martin luther king it was equality easy
to understand easy to share
so what is it for learning candy
right so so i can share it so i can tell
people about it and i can be proud of
these shirts so he loves the shirt but
it's not just about one shirt it's about
this movement that you're creating so
you're you're talking the right language
you're talking about movements i know
you've been watching my stuff if you're
saying that kind of like great
yes
and make it easy for me to make this
movement happen
okay so
next partnerships are great too and
there's so many organizations uh
that are community organizations that
are companies that are distributors who
sell to kids who sell the parents who
have kids
and that message is easy for them to
understand too but again you need to
come to them with a clear
message that they can understand
right because again whatever that
twitter bio thing is they're not gonna
you're not gonna get them inspired by
the curiosity confidence action
conscious inspiration and to succeed
right um
so
if you make it easy for them to
understand and see how your business
fits in with what they're doing
then they're more likely to say yes
and you can start with
mom groups there's tons of mom groups
that are community-led there are
small stores you know that might sell it
in their location or an online store if
you're only online right now right they
could sell your product as an extra line
and you can work your way up as you
build
momentum with it
but you need to again make this
something easy for people to understand
and to share
it makes sense definitely um just
getting your feedback definitely i can
definitely see that it's very high level
right now so i yeah that's feedback
so so okay so that's our high level
let's break it down so
homework
okay
right one word
learning candy in one word what it's all
about
then
make that message easy to understand on
your website and in all your social
media stuff so on your website if you
see that one word
uh i should i should know your story i
don't see that on your website maybe
it's somewhere missing uh
you know i don't know about us maybe
it's there but like
yeah yeah okay
it's not there i see your kids that's
great yeah you have a lot of text
so okay
make the text uh
easier to read because people like the
scan
so for example your text goes full width
across your website
people like reading down instead of a
cross so
shorter columns
point form headers pictures i love the
picture of your daughter here this is
great maybe it's a picture of you and
your daughter because i don't you know
stories about you so i'd love to see
that picture in there too
okay
then think about your your content
strategy so when you're promoting stuff
on i don't know if you have a blog but
uh you do have a blog so on your blog on
your twitter on your facebook again
you're looking at things that mean
something to you so you're either
sharing an important
you know like the world should be this
way kids
should be
raised this way you're taught this way
or inspired this way right like the
parents feel the same thing that you're
feeling but they don't know what to do
what do i do
right so if it's
if it's you know buy the clothing if
it's you know re read them you know show
them these examples what is it like give
me give me help parents are like they
live online
trying to find out
how to
educate their kids
so a combination of things that like
everything you you
make
you share whether it's something that
you've actually created yourself or
you're sharing somebody else's stuff
should get you excited should should
mean something to you like you wish you
saw this when your
daughter was born or when you were going
through this problem or continues to
inspire you
right and so posting these things on a
regular basis
you could start once a week twice a week
like you don't have to go crazy and do
five times a day because that can burn
you out
see what resonates with your audience
see what what uh
what feels
right you'll you'll make changes as you
go along that's okay so don't let like
if you don't have a perfect plan that's
okay
just start
but everything you post should get you
excited if it gets you excited it'll get
other people excited
and once you have that then you can
start reaching out to other
organizations either community groups
like moms uh either your you know past
customers through a newsletter or just
emailing them something once a month
that you feel is super important not
just not just your whatever sale you
have but again they should look forward
to an email from you
uh like if so for example on my
newsletter list
there are people who if i if i miss a
day
so you do it once a week usually on the
wednesday if i if i don't push out my
newsletter
people write to me and say what where's
the newsletter
right
would people do that i don't know if you
have a newsletter yet but would people
do that or not right if you don't tweet
for a week would people write this say
lana where's where are the tweets like
you have to be that important people's
lives and you can be right like they
should look forward to hearing from you
in a newsletter and reading your tweets
and on facebook
so it's not just promotional stuff it's
stuff that makes people feel something
and you can get that then you're
creating a movement the movement has to
start with a feeling
i have to care about what you're doing
and feel something towards your brain
so you're talking about like your
mindset is there you're talking you're
saying all the right things
now it's
taking action and doing it and getting
people to feel something about your
brand
big stance seven um if i may ask a
question yeah
uh now regarding building the actual
uh community um you know the things i'm
sharing on twitter you know goes mainly
to my followers or same with facebook as
far as building up the facebook
following building up the
twitter following
uh how would you recommend a go about
that
it's
it's posting things again that people
care about and want to share
so for example i just came back from um
i just did a twitter chat with uh with
dell i just came back from their office
i was like rushing back on the vespa to
get here for this call
and
we were talking about how do you find
your passion and we had i don't know how
many people joined it was it was crazy
it was like hundreds and hundreds of
questions coming in
uh and i was posting responses and
posting things that i felt strongly
about
they meant something to me right when i
tweet i
i put care into it and i'm trying to
speak from my heart things that i
believe in you may not agree with me i
might talk about starting the movement
and you might say evan that's stupid
what do you what do you don't know what
you're talking about i don't agree
that's cool right so
when i when i'm saying something
it means something to me and so those
tweets
were shared by my audience but then they
started sharing it with their audience
and other people started joining the
conversation people who had no idea who
they were they just started joining in
because they agreed with it too and they
had something to say and they wanted to
join the conversation
so that's the trick right at the start
it's going to feel like you're
you're talking to yourself
and
and it's
slow and painful and you feel like
you're all alone um
but if you're posting things that are
important to you
it'll be important to other people and
they will share it
and if you're doing that enough
then the people in your community who
are already following you and they're
sharing it their followers are going to
look at and say hey
this is great i got to follow learning
candy too they're going to check out
your stream to see all this great stuff
that you're providing they're going to
want to follow you
right you look at my twitter list i
don't do the
you know i'm following you so you're
going to follow me back all of that
stuff
i share great stuff that i love that
mean something to me
and my audience and it started off small
but my audience shared it
and then their audience found it and
they started following me right and
that's how it's built up
i have different communities in facebook
and youtube and twitter and some of them
overlap but a lot of them are
just
their own
isolated community and that's cool
but that's how you build it up right so
i'm a parent okay i have a son you know
you've given me a great shirt he's gonna
turn five soon and i look for ways to
to be a good dad
uh and
you know there's a lot of there's a lot
of guilt as a parent you think you're
doing the wrong thing and you're worried
you don't know what you're doing is this
the right decision or not
uh
you're trying to figure out the best
thing for them constantly there's a lot
of stress
and being a parent but if you were
giving me something
if you gave me stuff
that either
helped inspire my child uh or helped
inspire me
or made me feel like i'm not
alone in what i'm doing
or
showed an example of a of a parent who
you know
really love their kids or something you
know something that tugged at the
heartstrings i would follow you
and if i had something if i saw
something i really liked i would share
that
um
i think about this video about uh it was
an asian bank i think that made this
video
i was inspirational video basically
showing
the lengths that a father went through
to support his son and what he was
trying to do and then how the son then
leave the support of the father and
older age
and i i cried during the video and uh
and then i shared it and my audience
my audience started
uh looking at that video and saw it and
i exposed you know that bank to my
audience as well
um we got a question what's the question
from the audience oh they were asking me
about the evan carmichael believe shirt
that's not a learning candy special yet
at least but it might come that's uh
denny is asking a question about it
anyway um
but
that that's the point right like you
have to you have to share stuff that
makes you excited
and if you are really excited you feel
it the diff here's a difference okay
this is really important this is
everything in one thought
okay
a lot of times people share stuff
because they're on a schedule they have
a content schedule right i need to find
something today to post on twitter
and it ends up being something that's
just okay
where what you need to do is
i'd rather have you post less frequently
like don't stress out about in five
times a week but every time you post
it's important
it means something to you gets you
excited it relates to your one word
whatever that is
and the people who are on your list and
because your newsletter
twitter facebook everywhere the people
who are following you
look forward and are excited to get
information from you
if you can do that then they're going to
share it they're going to share your
stuff they're going to want to follow
you if you keep doing that then you're
really building a movement i know it's
hard at the beginning and it really
feels like you're just talking to
yourself
but
it's so important to get that right and
i'm a dad you know what i'll i will
follow you you should share some stuff
with me i'll follow you and if i like it
i'll share it too because i'm a dad
and i go through the same problem that
all parents go through and you're you
are solving such an important
problem for people
does that make sense
did i lose you
all right
okay i i see that evan and i
making it makes sense and definitely
very good advice very good advice
perfect sense look you know think back
um realizing that my most popular posts
on like facebook would be something that
always emotional that i mean it's okay
to have some practical things in there
have some practical stuff but anybody's
uh
lead with emotional stuff like 80
percent emotional stuff and then 20
practical hands-on
yeah
okay
uh wow we're we are we're over already
i've got to go i've actually got to go
pick up my son thank you
that's really good advice
you know do your homework if you want to
reach out to me with your your one word
we can go all right
thank you kevin great advice
no problem and for anybody watching
learningcandy.com you can go check it
out twitter learning candy get involved
give lama some advice let her know what
you think of her tweets
so thank you everybody watching thank
you lana and we'll see you everybody
soon
you